I recruited Arcane on my own for $0 the
series holds the record of being the
most expensive animated series ever
created now I wanted to see if I can
recreate a scene from the show without
spending any money at all all the tools
I use will be free and all the assets I
need will be made by me and after
looking at every official making of
material I could find I think I've not
only discovered the techniques they've
used to create the show but also what it
takes to create something truly special
yeah you make me
nous true this was probably the most
important part of this whole project if
I can't recreate this rocket launcher
close enough I might as well cancel the
whole project because it will only
really get harder from here and I need
it for the actual scene anyway so I
might as well start with it as a 3D
artist creating the model wasn't really
an issue I was more worried about the
special technique Arcane uses to shade
their 3D objects they paint every model
including some of the shadows and
highlights by hand the last time I
painted a model in this way it was
almost 2 years ago so I wasn't really
sure if I could recreate the style well
enough now I started by blocking out the
basic colors and some simple Shadows to
define the basic shapes of the model
afterwards I refined the most important
parts which also allowed me to add
smaller details that aren't actually in
the 3D model itself now it already looks
pretty good but it doesn't really react
to any Lighting in the 3D scene yet so
to finish it I plugged the final
textures into a Shader so that it looks
like it is actually living in the
environment around it and this is the
final result I think this looks good
enough to continue so now let's go a
little bit more in depth and see what it
takes to create a full Arcane style
animation St for a minute just like
creating the rocket launcher you can
separate the process for the whole
animation into two main steps as well
with one bonus Step at the end that the
creators like to call the secret
ingredient this three-step process is
what most objects go through to reach
their final look in the show including
of course Jinx no off I'm I'm try Focus
figh I started by sculpting her body
with the help of some references from
the
show in most big Productions you would
start with 2D concept art for each
character and then 3D artists try to cre
those Concepts as closely as
[Music]
possible the scene I'm trying to
recreate is the one at the end of season
1 where she fires the rocket launcher
for the first time I already have one
part of it so all that's missing now is
jinx there's also the environment but I
don't need to create a 3D model for that
and I will explain why a bit later
during the process for now the main and
most important goal is to recreate jinx
as closely as possible the biggest
problem with that is just like her
rocket launcher a lot of the details on
her have been added while painting her
textures they're not part of the actual
3D model which makes working with
references a lot harder luckily I
actually found a render of her without
the textures as well look at how
different she looks so much smoother
than you might expect this is
intentional to make the textures look as
good as possible once you add lighting
to them as well but that cre another
problem for me I can try to create the
3D model as closely as possible but
until I have painted her textures I
don't really know if I've captured her
look well enough if everything goes
wrong I might have to redo the whole 3D
model these moments of uncertainty
happened multiple times during this
project either because I had to work up
to a certain step to see if the results
look good enough or even worse I tried a
technique I've never really used before
and with jinx's body and outfit looking
pretty good so far one of those scary
steps was coming up next
the hair in Arcane has a very unique
look it's made up of these very big and
Broad shapes combined with smaller
sometimes very fine strands which
confused me a little bit at first I
watched every making off video I could
find to figure out how they created it
until I found this 1 second clip that
told me that they've used xgen it's a
common tool mainly used to create 3D
hairstyles with individual strands just
like real hair and unfortunately it's
part of Maya which costs all the money
so I had to stick to using blender
myself but now I had to make a decision
I can either create a reliable and
pretty good looking hairstyle with
blender's hair prodicle system or create
a great looking hairstyle by basically
programming my own unique hair system
using geometry nodes that is much
riskier unstable and might not even work
at all and could easily waste more than
20 hours in the process
I decided to do option two and guess
what it only took uh 44 hours and I'm
sure nothing will go wrong with it in
the future anyway let me show you how it
works to summarize the very boring math
behind this first you create a tube like
this then the system turns it into these
hair strands and afterwards you can
customize it with the settings the last
thing missing is the Shader which I
learned how to create through this
tutorial by lightning Boy Studio now
with her 3D model finished there are two
more steps to finish the 3D portion of
this project for her to move she needs
to have a rig basically a skeleton to
move the different parts of her body
this process can get very complex
depending on how much control you want
to have while animating luckily blender
has an amazing free add-on called rigify
that allows you to create one of these
complex rigs with a single button press
all you need to do is place the basic
bones and the add-on will do the rest
automatically and after a little bit of
tweaking and adjusting it works pretty
well you can actually do quite a lot
with this rig now but one thing you
can't do is this right here forti the
studio behind arcade not only used rigs
to control their characters but also
shape Keys shape keys are optional
deformations on the model that you can
use to create certain effects they're
often used for example to make
Expressions more expressive or here for
example they created them to make Jinx
look younger and more innocent I created
that same slider from my model 2 as well
as two more to have a bit more control
over her lips but you could go a lot
further with these if you really wanted
to and now the last 3D part of this
project is the actual animation of
course she can't just look like Jinx she
also needs to move like her so to
recreate the scene as closely as
possible I placed the original animation
with transparency over my 3D camera my
first goal was to match the most
significant poses as best as I can
afterwards I can blend between them with
a few more in between poses and blenders
automatic interpolation which fills the
rest of the frames this is actually how
most animations are created first you
lay out the most important poses then
you create the rest to blend between
them the difference between me and the
actual animators on Arcane is of course
that they didn't have this perfect
reference to trace instead they filmed
themselves acting out the scenes to
better understand how the character
needs to move during them so they don't
have to guess the whole animation
process went surprisingly smooth there
were not really any problems that
occurred during this step except for my
custom hair system of course and if I
can't fix this issue I might have to
create the entire hairstyle again from
scant with the other system but you know
what this can wait let's do something
more exciting
[Music]
first texture painting is one of the
things I was the least comfortable with
during this whole project but after
painting the rocket launcher I felt at
least a bit more confident in my skills
I basically just followed the same
process again first blocking out the
general shapes and colors then refining
everything and adding some more
[Music]
detail on its own blender's texture
painting has always been extremely
annoying and tedious to me but there
were two things I used during this
project that made the process a lot more
enjoyable the first is a free add-on
called yuku paint it adds essential
features like paint layers as well as
some really great quality of life
features like automatic Shadow
Generation or a much easier way to work
out basic colors if you do a lot of
texture painting this add-on is really
really good especially in combination
with the second thing which is my own
custom brush pack blender itself only
really has a single round default brush
which is exactly why I created this
brush pack with 50 custom brushes to
cover as many use cases as possible for
this Arcane project it actually worked
pretty well to only use the hard round
brush to paint everything but in my
previous project for example I use it to
paint This Grass Hill covered in snow
for my berserk animation or to recreate
this scene from Spirited Away if you're
interested in getting this pack for
yourself make sure to check out the
first link in the description and now
with my custom brushes in hand my plan
for the texture painting was once again
to only really refine the parts that are
clearly visible and leave the rest in a
fairly rough State just to save a little
bit of time that I could then use to fix
my hair system
[Music]
now it was finally time to see whether
my Jinx looks like the original or I
have to redo a bunch of stuff the
biggest thing I struggled with was
imitating this looseness that the
original has sometimes the colors blend
really well together and sometimes you
can clearly see some very broad brush
Strokes that look kind of rough but
still somehow work really well together
you can almost see the confidence and
intention behind every one of them the
confidence that I myself was lacking but
with enough time and patience I think I
am pretty happy with the result now
let's see if I can figure this miss out
and I actually did it only took 6 hours
this time basically nothing now it's
basically perfect except for this
flickering that I just could not nope
you know what I want that to be there
anyway speaking of texture painting I
also painted the environment well at
least partially I basically grabbed a
shot from the original and used photo a
free web version version of Photoshop to
remove Jinx from the shot and if that
didn't work completely I fixed the rest
in blender using texture painting now
there are only two more steps left
before the animation is fully done one
of them is fairly simple the other one
is the step I was the most excited but
also the most scared
[Music]
of the first one are the 2D VFX in the
actual show 2D animators created these
extra Effects by painting on top of the
3D animation probably in a software made
for 2D animation that costs a lot of
money but you can create something
pretty similar in blender as well by
adding a grease pencil object into the
3D scene you can paint basically
anywhere in 3D space so to paint the VX
on top I just place the drawing layer in
front of my 3D camera so it covers the
scene behind it now all I had to do is
redraw the animation from the original
frame by frame which wasn't really that
hard it just took a long time
[Music]
time for this I also decided not to
trace the frames exactly like I did for
the 3D animations because I thought
drawing them myself would be more fun
it's a pretty simple process overall and
I'm sure I've missed some steps that
made this process a lot better but also
a lot harder in the actual show but
that's how I created these shots for my
own version now on to the last and
probably also most important step of
them
all the secret ingredient that makes
Arcane look so great this tiny clip
perfectly shows what that means all the
elements of the scene are already there
in the shot but what gives the show its
unique look and feel is being created
during the composition stage they are
intentionally vague about this process
in they're making off videos so it's
hard to find any concrete info but
here's how I think they did it looking
at this clip again the process seems to
start with the raw textures without any
lighting then during compositing the
lighting gets added in some sort of way
on top of that we can also see some more
typical effects like lens dird or glare
that you would usually add during
compositing as well as the 2D effects of
course that need to be combined with the
3D animation at some point to me it
seems like they collect all the elements
that make up a scene separately and then
combine them all together in compositing
to create the final look the reason why
I think they do it that way is because
that gives them ultimate creative
control don't like the shading on the
face just remove it from where you don't
want it and enhance it where you need
more don't like the hair color well now
you can change it want to put more
emphasis on the eyes select only the
eyes to brighten them so they stick out
more this ultimate flexibility is I
think what allowed them to create such a
unique animation style in the first
place the 3D render gives you photo
realistic shading but you don't have to
use it if you think it looks better
without it maybe you want to add your
own lighting whatever it is you can do
it now I think I managed to create some
of this myself but I'm still very
unexperienced in the step of the process
so it could have been a lot better but I
think that's also another maybe the most
important reason for why Arcane looks
and feels so good it's because so many
experts from so many different fields
came together to create this show as a
single person you only have a limited
amount of time to learn all parts of the
process so you'll never be as good as
someone who has dedicated their life to
one of those things by yourself you
might be able to create something great
but only with a team can you go beyond
that and create something truly
remarkable I drift
as to find you in my dream
tell me is it real cuz I wake up feeling
like it
[Music]
is you make me nous yes true